Despite popular belief, there are actually
a handful of characters that David and Dan
managed to do justice in the later
seasons. Which is where I’m going to
be focusing primarily because this list would
be full of amazing characters who died in the
earlier seasons like Tywin and Joffrey
that David and Dan physically couldn’t
ruin. So the requirement is that they have
to be alive in at least season 7 or 8. Also,
I feel like it would kind of be cheating
if I picked minor side characters like Pod
the Rod because they have very little screen
time and development. Without further ado -
Number 10, Sansa Stark. Now I know this may
be initially controversial, but keep in mind,
it’s really hard to find 10 good characters that
weren’t ruined. So the first half of this list
still has characters that are partially ruined.
Sansa out of all the main characters to me has
the best executed arc that doesn’t have a bunch
of major flaws. There are definitely aspects
about it that are still flawed like there
not being a lot of defining moments in her
arc that show her progress, and then multiple
minor issues that start to add up. Examples of
those issues include her general stupidity in
certain areas like not telling Jon about the
Vale and overly trusting Littlefinger in season
7, and the general contriveness surrounding her
character like unjustifiably hating Daenerys
so much. Also, it would definitely be nice if
we saw more development of Sansa overcoming
the conflicts of running a massive kingdom
and the North as a whole. There’s easily a
lot of conflict that you can brew up in this
setting especially given the circumstances
of the story. Throughout the later seasons,
we are essentially just told how great of a leader
Sansa is, but David and Dan never really show us
that. They focus a lot of the show’s time in
other areas and probably think the complexities
of running a kingdom is boring when it isn’t. Like
look at the earlier seasons of the show or even
House of the Dragon. Sansa essentially falls
victim to the rushing of the story, however,
from a story perspective there’s nothing that
obliterates her character. It’s all partially
logical, she has a believable character arc, and
she has arguably the best ending out of the main
characters. On top of her consistently being
relevant within the story, unlike some other
characters. So overall, you kind of have to squint
your eyes when viewing Sansa because her general
form is intact, but the second you focus your eyes
and look at the details it mostly falls apart.
Number 9, Samwell Tarly. Samwell as a character
isn’t entirely unscathed and still has some shaky
aspects about himself. But in an overall sense,
Samwell Tarly from a personality perspective
is relatively fine and not overly destroyed. The
couple bad aspects about him that I’m referring to
is Samwell becoming Sam the Slayer and him easily
becoming the grandmaester of Kingslanding without
proper training. The first one is obviously pretty
rough, however, I’m willing to slightly look past
this since everyone became immortal gods with
plot armor during that episode. Then for the
second one, him becoming grandmaester is kind of
a fan service ending that doesn’t make sense due
to his relative inexperience, but it at least is
the correct direction for the character. Samwell
also doesn’t have a lot to do in the final season
and basically is just there to tell Jon he’s a
Targaryen, but his season 6 and 7 goal was pretty
important in that he learns about the deposit of
dragon glass in Dragonstone. Along with him being
a P.O.V. character. His relationship with Gilly
and his son is largely overlooked and Sam is
essentially the middle road character where
David and Dan didn’t do anything great with
him, nor did they decimate him like Tyrion.
Number 8, Tormund. Now Tormund in
comparison to Samwell is kind of
the opposite. I think his character in
terms of how he’s implemented into the
story doesn’t do anything overly stupid
that does a disservice to him. However,
I think David and Dan have severely dumbed down
his character since the earlier seasons. He more
or less has become just a comedic relief character
when he used to also be a more intimidating, bold,
and serious wildling who has sporadic bursts
of comedy to release any built-up tension. It
makes sense for his character to become more
friendly over the seasons, but I think David
and Dan do it so much to the point that he loses
an integral aspect about himself. Like the whole
Brienne bait romance was funny at first and it
essentially becomes a weird fan service-esque
meme that keeps returning that simultaneously robs
the character of any seriousness. Along with them
doing overly silly things with the character
like chugging giant’s milk for a century. He’s
still a very fun and enjoyable figure to watch,
but he does lose that layer of depth from the
earlier seasons that balanced him out. That’s
why I’m putting him at number 9 since he has
this one negative aspect, but he’s still largely
intact to the point that he’s not overly ruined.
Number 7, Davos Seaworth. This is a character
that I see a lot of love for and to me,
I never really loved him that much. In his
earlier seasons, he’s obviously great like
in his wonderful pairing with Shireen and his
morally complex pairing with Stannis Baratheon,
however, after season 5, he spontaneously joins
Jon’s side and becomes his yes man. Like Tormund,
I think he loses a lot of his complexity and David
and Dan don’t do a lot with his character to make
him overly interesting. He’s my definition of
the most neutral character in the later seasons.
An example of an easy-hanging fruit to develop
Davos is the death of Mathos and whether or not
he’s still mad at Tyrion for that. Instead, that
goes unexplored and you probably can’t think of
anything personal about the character that gets
developed in the later seasons. He’s kind of just
along for the ride and fundamentally supports
Jon. Like that’s fine and on a technicality,
he isn’t ruined, but he also isn’t doing
anything impressive within the story.
Number 6, Grey Worm. Similar to Davos, Grey Worm
is a very simple character that you really can’t
mess up that badly. Although, David and Dan
still mess up one aspect about him towards
the end in which he flat out doesn’t kill Jon,
which essentially acts as a plot contrivance,
but besides that he has a good revenge arc. His
romance with Missendei was really gratifying
since it’s two characters so entrenched in misery
for their entire lives and they finally find love
that reinvigorates them. To then have that all
ripped away by an evil queen makes Grey Worm’s
pure rage deeply connecting. Grey Worm because of
this ironically has a better mad queen arc than
Daenerys because it’s much more justified
and you understand his perspective more,
albeit it’s obviously more simple. I just wish
they pushed that anger-fueled side of him more
and had him show down against Jon at the end
because that’s really the more realistic path to
take his character. Given that he was executing
prisoners for breathing. Not him allowing these
traitors to do whatever they want in the end
and all of his anger evaporating. However,
I think Grey Worm’s ending of honoring Missendei
is still pretty wholesome and works well too. Just
don’t tell them that there’s apparently poisonous
butterflies on Naath that will decimate them.
Number 5, Olenna Tyrell. I would put Olenna a
bit higher, but I feel like that would kind of
be cheating since she really isn’t in the
later seasons all that much. David and Dan
really nailed her two scenes within season 7
in which she gives some great advice to Dany
and has one of the best death scenes in the
show. Like it’s genuinely pretty jarring how
good her overall death scene was in comparison
to so many of the other mediocre to terrible
scenes within the season. One aspect that really
carries it is that it’s long awaited payoff in
that Olenna finally gets to tell Jaime that
she killed Joffrey. It leads to the juiciest
of reactions and Dianna Rigg absolutely nails
the scene and utterly relishes in the pain and
misery of Jaime Lannister. That smug little
smile she gives Jaime is such an iconic moment
that it easily cements itself as one of the best
scenes in the later seasons. Then besides this,
her talk with Daenerys feels the most genuine
because she’s actually giving her good advice,
unlike Tyrion. Olenna encouraging Dany to become a
Targaryen and not be afraid to show her true power
was what should have happened all along and
it’s too bad she didn’t listen to her. Olenna
may only have a couple of scenes within season
7, but they were impactful enough to land her
onto my list because of how perfectly executed
they were and how great of a character she was.
Number 4, Theon Grejoy. From an overall character
arc perspective, Theon is pretty flawless. He has
the most consistent and tangible arc in the show
to the point that it would be almost impossible to
mess up and David and Dan don’t. They still rough
it up a bit towards the beginning of season 8,
but it wasn’t terrible. David and Dan have this
grand set-up for Theon’s redemption in saving
Yara by finally becoming a confident and fearless
leader. He overcomes the nightmare of Reek and
finally takes back his true identity of being
a Greyjoy. However, it seems that David and Dan
didn’t really carry over this effort into season
8 because Theon simply waltzs into Euron’s fleet
at night, kills a couple of guards, and rescues
Yara with almost no conflict. It’s a little bit
of a bummer that there wasn’t a grand rescue
kind of heist that has more impactful payoff
or even overcoming Euron, someone that Theon
previously ran away from. Honestly thinking
about it now it would make much more sense for
Theon to kill Euron than Jaime. Luckily though,
this was the only mistep. His reunion
with Sansa is really sweet and heartfelt,
and the irony in that he dies protecting Bran,
a character he was thought of for killing,
is actually some brilliant writing. He may
not have a lot of screen time and really
dialogue scenes even, but these points in
his character arc are pretty much perfect.
Number 3, Jorah Mormont. Ser Jorah is just barely
included enough in the story to not feel left out
and even though I’d like some more dialogue scenes
for him, you could essentially say that for most
of the side characters in the later seasons.
The main reason why I’m putting him at number
3 is that his ending was by far the best thing to
have happened during The Long Night. He may have
kind of teleported outside of Winterfell to save
Daenerys in that moment, but heyyy, I’ll give it
a pass since it makes sense from a character
standpoint and not necessarily a contextual
logistics standpoint. But at least in comparison
to say Theon, there isn’t a major aspect during
his journey that was very underwhelming. His
reunion scenes were charged with so much heart
and emotion, his character pairings were all
very intriguing, so much to the point that you
just want more of them, and he was even regularly
included in the action. Ser Jorah is essentially
my go-to for one of the most consistently good
side characters. Aided with the fact that his
overall story arc isn’t that complex so David
and Dan couldn’t really ruin it that badly.
Number 2, Brienne of Tarth. I think she’s one
of two characters that genuinely have some great
character development in season 8. Because that’s
the main thing about Theon and Jorah in that their
character journeys essentially just come to an end
without them changing a lot. Which obviously isn’t
a bad thing. Meanwhile, Brienne goes through
an entire end goal payoff for her character in
which she finally becomes a knight, she finds
love, and achieves an ultimate goal. On top of
there still being some good buildup to Jaime and
Brienne's romance in which Jaime dismantles the
mean figure she viewed him as. Just the knighting
scene alone would easily put Brienne within my
top 3 and is probably the best scene in season 8.
The genuine and serene happiness that gushes from
both of these characters is massively cathartic
and it’s one of those rare victories within Game
of Thrones. It’s also written really well in
having the scene slowly progress and build the
excitement as the ceremony goes on. Along with
Ramin Djawadi elevating the wonderful emotions
with his outstanding music. Then you can’t
help but feel so much joy for the character
as she finally finds love in her life. That’s
something that she’s always struggled with and
was emotionally beat down by, so having this
love scene was great for the character. Even
though Jaime leaves right away, the love
doesn’t disappear and even she partially
redeems Jaime’s ending with yet another great
scene in which she fills the white book with all
of Jaime’s good deeds. Through and through
a really well done job and the main reason
why she isn’t in my number one spot is that
she didn’t have anything to do in season 7.
Number 1, Sandor Clegane. I feel like the
primary reason why David and Dan were able
to not ruin Sandor as a character is because
he fundamentally plays into their writing
strengths. And those strengths are generally
more vulgar based comedy. Given that it seems
David and Dan fall back on that kind of dialogue
a lot in the later seasons. Although, Sandor was
really the only character that wasn’t hurt by
this. If anything, it even helped him since he
had a lot of iconic funny moments. Sandor uses
humor as both a way to destroy people and even
as a defense mechanism. The only person that
can get past this defense is Arya given that
she’s spent so much time with him. Like seeing
them together and witnessing a more mellowed out
Hound was genuinely outstanding and I’m really sad
we didn’t get more of that. Like that was one of
my favorite aspects from seasons 3 and 4. Their
duo is infectious and having his arc coincide
with Arya’s in that he shows her how revenge
consumed himself and convinces her to escape was
honestly pretty good. It’s a perfect arc for the
character and even pairs well with an additional
main character. Then his ending was also great
and even though it was a bit fan servicey,
I can easily forgive it given that there were
far greater issues about the episode. Having
both the Hound and the Mountain die to fire
was surprisingly poetic. Both from a character
perspective and his relevance within the story,
the Hound was consistently amazing and prevalent
throughout. I know him coming back into the story
in season 6 is kind of a hot topic, but between
all of the absurdly dumb things that happen later
on, it’s not a major deal. That and the direction
it put the character in was actually interesting.
Thank god David and Dan did a great job with
Sandor Clegane because he has always been one of
my favorites. Unlike what they did with Tyrion.
Thank you for watching and this video
was a part of a double feature. So
check out The Top 10 Characters
Ruined by David and Dan. Also,
let me know in the comments what
your ranking would be for this video.